today fathers are preparing their
daughters for divorce they're preparing
make sure you've got your career if he
does this that you don't rely on him it
is all based on what prepare for divorce
not prepare for marriage
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be for you because every
person that comes a step closer to Allah
through your donation you and the
Charlotte American reward click the link
and donate what you can assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
let's get straight into this video this
video for some might be disturbing for
some it will be enlightening and for
some it's damn about time that we advise
our daughters and also our sons but in
this very instance it's the father
advising the daughter I have three
daughters and I would say if they happen
to see this video and they've reached
the age that they married and in my life
to see that I would love to say these
words to her myself or if for example I
am I've passed away that they become a
cedar hajaria may Allah bless them and
Grant them righteous partners that they
watch this video and that they know
their father Ali yep condones every
single word this man says we're going to
come to one specific bit but let's watch
it for ourselves inshallah because I do
not say anything to anybody unless I do
it for myself like the prophet sallam
said if I caught Fatima stealing I would
cut her hand off because this one didn't
teach us not one rule for someone else
or the other or something for another no
way let's watch this video for ourselves
inshallah if your discretion might be
advised
foreign
[Music]
all right guys now let's understand and
put some context to this now you heard
that for yourself now brothers and
sisters you need to understand something
today fathers are preparing their
daughters for divorce they're preparing
make sure you've got your career if he
does this that you don't rely on him it
is all based on what prepare for divorce
not prepare for marriage prepare for
divorce not only the father also The
Mother We Are nurturing the next
generation of our daughters or our sons
yes and I'm gonna be talking about why
I'm talking about the sisters yeah
specifically you're going to find out
why are we preparing our next Generation
I will do test for divorce why this is
devastating catastrophic the biggest
threat to the Omar right now is divorce
rates why now I said to you guys I would
say the same words to my daughter now
you might be watching the same thing
very disturbing I'll say you're
disturbed you're tapped in the head yes
why because he has said nothing wrong
there and that is what the dean says I
dare anybody that's watching this to
come and tell me that what he said is
Haram no because Allah says
the men are the maintainers and
protectors and obedience yes that word
obedience which nobody likes what to who
now if I give my daughter's hand in
marriage to a man best believe and best
know that I am seeing that I trust her
decision she's made to take him as a
leader as a man who's going to provide
protect love her care for her good now
does this mean that if my daughter comes
and complains to me I'm going to say go
back to your husband no because I know
women are born emotional by their nature
so therefore my daughter comes to me
complaining about certain matter of
course I'm going to listen to it of
course I'm going to hear out but if it's
an issue which is petty yes and that
varies from place to place if it's an
issue where somebody else is involved
where her friend or someone else or even
be it my own wife involved if she was
involved in her marriage disputes I will
tell her is your husband providing for
you okay does he protect you yes does he
do this shopping yes is he loving to you
yes to the kids yes good does he pray
yes as taqwa yes the disputes that you
have keep them to yourself unless it is
something severe unless he's violating
the laws of Allah unless he's violating
your rights come and see me if any of
those are not happening stay in your
marriage do not let anyone destroy it
why because 80 percent of the time we
studies show that women are initiating
divorce and these women most of the time
end up regretting it a woman can be
emotional they could say things that
they don't mean that is within their
nature understandable so if women are
initiating divorce 80 of the time that
means that they are prone to initiative
divorce that man has to be the leader
and say no and take things in control
not be emotional like her so what this
man is seeing I'm asking a question to
all the fathers out there specifically
which you guys know which I'm known for
the second wife the same goals again
she's telling her he's telling his
daughter that if he happens to do that
yes can be like okay if he gets another
one support him of course the woman is
jealous of course she's not going to be
happy that is all well and good the best
of the woman were not happy the best of
the woman smash plays the best of the
Believers our mothers got angry and then
all kinds of stuff subhanallah yes and
some of the scholars even say that they
were not even blameworthy of that so
therefore we understand the woman's
nature of being upset however asking for
a divorce because your husband like
again a good man who's protecting who's
providing who loves you cares about you
getting married again I would say the
same thing to my daughter and for those
of you guys who think this is abnormal
if there's anyone abnormal it is you
because I am following what the theme
says if my daughter comes to me and says
my husband has decided to get married
again I'll ask the same questions again
is he a good man yes he is practicing
yes loves you yes takes care of you yes
looks after the kids yes spends time
with you yes praise to Allah yes because
his father yes yes yes I will say you my
daughter which I love and I want the
best for you you might hate something
which is good for you and you might love
something which is bad for you this is
what the dentist does not the liberal
principles of the the god of good and
the good god of evil yes with the
pleasure of pain no no no no no we say
might be Pluto you might dislike it but
there is goodness in you because if that
is the case that he's a good man do not
lose him because don't think for a
second that the next man you're going to
marry is going to be anyway any shape
different no he's gonna come in a
different form like the second law of
Thermodynamics which you're gonna be
thinking what has this got to do with
anything yeah I'll wrap up with this is
that energy cannot be created or
destroyed meaning if I set this watch on
fire it's going it's not gonna it's
gonna disappear the energy is going to
change into a different form yes this
integrates uh to the clouds whatever
it's going to happen but it is still
there it's just change form therefore
anything Allah is legislated we need
more fathers like this man who entrust
his daughter to a good man and if the
man violates the woman in her family
energy which the man crumbles to your
femininity is your biggest power against
the man I'm telling you sisters your
femininity is the greatest mass
destructional weapon that you have
against your husband he will crumble
trust me and anytime you have a dispute
Allah says in the Quran get family
members involved alhamdulillah but in a
nutshell if anybody is watching this the
feminists they would be ripping their
hair out is she a property shut up shut
up get get lost it's you woman that have
destroyed the woman of today that they
have become anything anything something
small happens divorce and we will be
reacting to a video pertaining to this
with sis Neymar Roberts and myself of
another sister who is advising a woman
to go their separate ways because of
something so minor that's all I'm going
to say may Allah preserve this father
and his daughter and their marriage and
their husbands nobody in any way she
performed is seeing in this video that
if this woman is being violated with her
eyes are not being given that she shot
something to be quite no Islam has given
the woman the right that even if she is
sexually not satisfied she has a right
to ask for divorce the point here is
this that a man deals with a man and if
my daughter came to me and her husband
was violating her I will be dealing with
him in a way that befits him so may
Allah allow us to go back to our
Traditions go back to our Islamic values
and have trust and tawakul in Allah's
legislation that we do not put our trust
in what we think we know but rather what
Allah did only we will be then
successful only then these divorce rates
won't be happening only then he won't
have abundance of single fathers and
single mothers and corrupt broken down
children who are psychologically
affected by the breakdown of the family
unit may Allah bless you guys inshallah
we will be probably reacting to this on
the bittertube show when we're recording
our next episode till next time
please do give me your comments and
thoughts on the comment section
inshallah I'll see you guys soon
[Music]
um
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah in the country of
Norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of Allah